il a eu une année formidable
michael bryce est le garde du corps de l'
année
une fois bien ce n'est pas une nuit,
je pense que tu dois oublier le
garde du corps
[Musique]
je suis officiellement en congé sabbatique et pour être
honnête je ne sais pas pourquoi je ne l'ai pas fait
plus tôt
en attendant que
je fasse ce changement
pour la première fois je commence à
imaginer une vie sans garde du corps
cela ressemble vraiment à
des ordres psychologiques
des fois tu as failli
me faire tuer
pas assez
je ferais une super mère tu ne penses pas
oh mon dieu un enfant aurait tellement de
chance de t'avoir comme hôte
je d'autre part te dirai
tout
[Musique]